lisa war eine influenza er in der
rechtsradikalen szene in deutschland
monatelang hätten sie auf youtube gegen
muslime migranten und migrantinnen und
gegen die regierung
machen
mit ihren auftritten in den sozialen
medien erreichte sie hunderttausende
menschen
angst schon um die person soweit zu
manipulieren dass die einem am ende
alles glauben und dann auch zu allem
bereit sind
lisa ist mittlerweile aus der rechten
szene ausgestiegen ihren nachnamen
sollen wir nicht nennen sie erhält
morddrohungen von früheren weggefährten
und doch spricht sie heute offen darüber
wie rechte über die sozialen medien
junge menschen auf ihre seite ziehen es
beginnt meist ganz harmlos
rechtsradikale präsentieren auf
plattformen wie instagram eine
vermeintlich heile welt
glatze bomberjacke und springerstiefel
sieht man aufrechten kanälen kaum noch
statt dessen bilder die werte
transportieren die häufig von rechten
instrumentalisiert werden
traditionen natur gemeinschaft
unpolitisch und unproblematisch wirkt
das ganze nur auf den ersten blick
der hinsicht
brandbeschleuniger in
radikalisierungsprozess weil sie einfach
so so unschuldig und so unverfänglich
rüberkommen das ist glaube ich dass das
größte problem an der sache das sind
eben
ausdrucksweisen die die nicht unbedingt
auch ein rechtsextremes weltbild hindern
mit instagram pos und youtube videos
können rechte unkontrolliert die massen
erreichen mit geschickt gestalteten
inhalten führen sie fremdenhass und
nationalismus das ziel ein möglichst
niedrigschwelliger einstieg in die
rechtsextreme gedankenwelt der
manipulative umgang mit den sozialen
medien wird sogar in schulungen
vermittelt zum beispiel organisiert von
rechtsextremen gruppen wie der
identitäten bewegung oder der
jugendorganisation der
rechtspopulistischen partei alternative
für deutschland
diese erzählt dass sie bei so einer
schulung dabei war
es ging darum wie tritt man auch im
internet als person bekleidet man sich
wie wirkt man seriösen der neue rechte
hat jetzt schon haarschnitte trägt
polohemd er ist gebildet er hat einen
guten schulabschluss er möchte familie
ertrinkt kein alkohol ergebnis auf
rechts rockkonzerte es ist ein
kompletter wandel und den bekommt man da
sehr sehr gut vermittelt diese form der
subtilen politischen einflussnahme
scheint zu greifen und wird laut
experten noch verstärkt durch
algorithmen und filter blasen der
sozialen medien